if a man empties his purse into his head
no one can take it from him
having been poor is no shame
but being ashamed of it is
never ruin an apology with an excuse
whatever is begun in anger
ends in shame
if you would know the value of money
go and try to borrow some
time is money
i didn't fail the test
i just found 100 ways to do it wrong
you may delay
but time will not
love your enemies
for they tell you your faults
there are three faithful friends
an old wife
an old dog
and ready money
beware of little expenses
a small leak will sink a great ship
well done is better than well said
many people die at 25
and aren't buried until they are 75
by failing to prepare
you are preparing to fail
no gains without pains
life's biggest tragedy is that we get
old too soon
and wise too late
one today is worth two tomorrows
laziness travels so slowly
that poverty soon overtakes him
rather go to bed without dinner
than to rise in debt
at 20 years of age the will reigns
at 30
the wit
and at 40
the judgment
never leave till tomorrow
bad which you can do today
to succeed jump as quickly at
opportunities as you do at conclusions
lost time is never found again
an investment in knowledge pays the best
interest
where there is marriage without love
there will be love without marriage
haste makes waste
three may keep a secret
if two of them are dead
he that lies down with dogs
shall rise up with fleas
to find out a girl's faults
praise her to her girlfriends
doust thou love life
then do not squander time
for that's the stuff life is made of
educate your children to self-control
to the habit of holding passion and
prejudice
and evil tendencies subject to an
upright and reasoning will
and you have done much to abolish misery
from their future
and crimes from society
keep your eyes wide open before marriage
half shut afterwards
we do not stop playing because we grow
old
we grow old because we stop playing
work as if you were to live a thousand
years
play as if you were to die tomorrow
contentment makes poor men rich
discontent makes rich men poor
vice knows that he is ugly
so he puts on a mask
he that displays too often his wife and
his wallet is in danger of having both
of them borrowed
fatigue is the best pillow
the discontented man finds no easy chair
buy what thou hast no seed of
and air long thou shalt sell thy
necessities
you will find the key to success
under the alarm clock
either write something worth reading
or do something worth writing
they who can give up essential liberty
to obtain a little temporary safety
deserve neither liberty
nor safety
tell me
and i forgot
teach me
and i may remember
involve me and i learn
he that can have patience
can have what he will
a penny saved is a penny earned
in wine there is wisdom
in beer there is freedom
in water
there is bacteria
we are all born ignorant
but one must work hard to remain stupid
justice will not be served until those
who are unaffected are as outraged as
those who are
fear not death
for the sooner we die
the longer we shall be immortal
wine is proof that god loves us
and wants us to be happy
it is the first responsibility of every
citizen to question authority
instead of cursing the darkness
light a candle
if all printers were determined not to
print anything till they were sure it
would offend nobody
there would be very little printed
be at war with your vices
at peace with your neighbors
and let every new year find you a better
man
early to bed and early to rise
makes a man healthy wealthy
and wise
never confuse motion with action
the heart of a fool is in his mouth
but the mouth of a wise man is in his
heart
there was never a bad peace
or a good war
be slow in choosing a friend
slower in changing
we must all hang together
or assuredly we shall all hang
separately
when you are finished changing
you're finished
when you're testing to see how deep
water is
never use two feet
an ounce of prevention
is worth a pound of cure
a slip of the foot you may soon recover
but a slip of the tongue
you may never get over
happiness depends more on the inward
disposition of mind
than on outward circumstances
do not trust your money to a person who
likes to count
other people's money
be civil to all
sociable to many
familiar with few
friend to one
enemy to none
if a man could have half of his wishes
he would double his troubles
speak ill of no man
but speak
all the good you know of everybody
if you want to be rich
learn not only to earn
but also to be economical
the way to see by faith
is to shut the eye of reason
a house is not a home
unless it contains food and fire for the
mind
as well as the body
security without liberty
is called prison
those things that hurt
instruct
you